stimmen für spätere lockerung immer mehr
politiker sprechen sich dafür aus die
korona beschränkungen bis in den
dezember hinein zu verlängern
mission mit regieren die grünen
beschließen ein neues grundsatzprogramm
und wollen mehr bürgerbeteiligung und
deutscher doppelerfolg gleich zu
saisonbeginn gewinnt markus eisenbichler
den skisprung-weltcup in polen zweiter
wird karl geiger
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
ballweg guten abend und willkommen an
meiner seite ist rudi cerne für den
sport hallo guten und auf welche
einschränkungen müssen wir uns bis
weihnachten einstellen darüber
entscheiden am mittwoch bund und länder
schon jetzt fordern einige die korona
maßnahmen zu verlängern oder sogar zu
verschärfen
dennoch zeigen die seit drei wochen
geltenden einschränkungen nicht die
erhoffte wirkung david sauer protest
gegen die korona politik wie hier in
berlin heute auch in einigen anderen
städten
doch ihre forderungen nach einem
baldigen ende der maßnahmen wird sich
wohl nicht erfüllen
er ist eine verlängerung des teil
shutdowns wahrscheinlich beim nächsten
bund-länder-treffen am mittwoch
jedenfalls haben weder sozialdemokraten
noch union derzeit eine gangbare
alternative anzubieten
die zahlen sind einfach viel zu hoch die
infektionszahlen die krankenhäuser
laufen voll auch die todeszahlen
steigungen insofern ist klar es gibt
keinen anlass zu einer entwarnung auch
nicht zu einem teil entwarnung sondern
wir müssen uns leider mit der tatsache
vertraut machen dass der doktorand
verlängert wird nachholbedarf sieht auch
die bundeskanzlerin bittet aber um
geduld bis mittwoch dem kann ich und
will ich auch heute nicht vorgreifen
weil die bürgerinnen und bürger sollen
von bund und ländern eine geschlossene
gemeinsame antwort bekommen darauf haben
sie eigentlich ein recht und daran
arbeiten wir jetzt diesmal sehr intensiv
derzeit infizieren sich je 100.000
einwohner in sieben tagen bundesweit 139
ziel sind weniger als 50 liegt der wert
höher überlastet langfristig das
gesundheitssystem sagen experten
viele haben derzeit den advent im blick
fragen sich wie in einem monat das
weihnachtsfest unter kroner bedingungen
aussehen wird die kalte jahreszeit ist
dann aber noch lange nicht vorbei
deshalb brauche es eine strategie für
den ganzen winter fordert etwa die
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern
wir brauchen auf jeden fall eine
langfristperspektive wir müssen am
mittwoch den bereichen die geschlossen
sind aber vor allem der ganzen
bevölkerung sagen wie wir durch den
winter kommen es ist wichtig dass wir
weiter schutzmaßnahmen im dezember und
januar haben zum beispiel strenge
kontakt beschränkungen
der schweigemarsch in berlin war am ende
ganz und gar nicht still
gegen demonstranten machten jede menge
lernen aber alles friedlich und geordnet
angemeldet waren 5000 personen rund 1000
zählte die polizei bei nicht alle
gesundheitsämter am wochenende daten
übermitteln sind die korona zahlen
sonntags in der regel etwas niedriger so
auch heute
laut robert koch institut gab es binnen
24 stunden 15 1741 neuinfektionen
das sind 1200 sechs weniger als
vergangenen sonntag die zahl der
todesfälle im zusammenhang mit dem virus
stieg um 138 wie groß ist die korona
gefahr in bus und bahn in unserer zdf
heute app zeigen wir welche faktoren
eine rolle spielen und warum politiker
und wissenschaftler dazu aufrufen
öffentliche verkehrsmittel wenn möglich
zu meiden
finanzminister scholz will für das
kommende jahr offenbar deutlich mehr
schulden aufnehmen als bisher bekannt
statt 96 milliarden mindestens 160
milliarden berichten verschiedene medien
scholz selbst sagt aber für die jahre
2020 21 zusammen genommen werde der
korridor zitat ungefähr der gleiche
bleiben am donnerstag in der
haushaltsausschuss weiter über den
haushalt 2021 beraten
die grünen wollen in die regierung das
wurde bei ihrem virtuellen parteitag
deutlicher denn je nach 18 jahren haben
sie zudem ein neues grundsatzprogramm
verabschiedet das soll noch mehr
wählerinnen und wähler ansprechen
die drei großen streitthemen dabei
klimawandel volksentscheide innere
sicherheit
andreas huppert und las bohnsack
berichten abschluss eines historischen
grünen parteitags dem ersten digital ein
neues grundsatzprogramm ist beschlossen
leitlinien gemacht nicht nur für
mitglieder sondern mit dem anspruch auf
umsetzen
das nächste jahrzehnt das wird
entscheidend sein sei es beim
klimaschutz sei es für den zusammen
sozialen zusammenhalt in unserem land
und jetzt in einer pandemie wo sich
dinge neu sortieren haben wir die
grundlage dafür geschaffen dinge auch
wirklich anders
und zwar besser zu machen die themen
bereit grundsatzprogramm eben natürlich
mit klimaschutz dazu innere sicherheit
gentechnik bis hin zum heutigen
streitthema direkte demokratie viele aus
der partei wollen volksabstimmungen auf
bundesebene ich bin dir also dafür die
ruhe die angst vor den wunsch das
mitmachen und mitbestimmen
menschen die parteispitzen robert habeck
will bürger rede statt volksabstimmungen
dabei sollen per los ausgewählte bürger
an gesetzen mitarbeiten dürfen
volksentscheide werden polarisieren es
sind ja nein entscheidung es ist schwarz
oder weiß sie werden nicht den diskurs
der gesellschaft beförderung und über
die streichung wieder gesetzt am ende
heißt es keine volksabstimmungen und
auch bei der absenkung des wahlalters
auf 16 jahre statt auf 14 setzt sich der
vorstand jede zeit hat ihre farbe so der
parteitag slogan demonstrativ
geschlossen mit dem willen zu regieren
ziehen die grünen ins kommende wahljahr
seit 15 wochen gibt es in belarus trotz
polizeigewalt jeden sonntag proteste
gegen machthaber lukaschenko auch heute
wieder in der hauptstadt minsk
versammelten sich die menschen in ihren
wohnvierteln da weite teile der
innenstadt mit metall gittern abgesperrt
waren
hundertschaften von polizei und armee
setzten blendgranaten ein und nahmen
laut einer menschenrechtsorganisation
mehr als 200 demonstranten fest
erst die korona pandemie in den griff
kriegen und dann der globalen wirtschaft
wieder auf die sprünge helfen das hat
sich grob gesagt die g20 also die gruppe
der großen industrienationen zum
abschluss ihres virtuellen gipfels
vorgenommen
aber auch der klimawandel treibt sie um
anna klinik kein damen oder
kulturprogramm kein austausch von
regierungs chefs und chefinnen am rande
dieser von saudi arabien organisierte
video gipfel war anders als alle zuvor
der kampf gegen die korona pandemie hat
das treffen überschattet die g20
teilnehmer wollen für eine gerechte
verteilung von impfstoffen sorgen doch
fehlt es noch an geld die beschlüsse
bleiben
glücklicherweise kann man sagen gibt es
jetzt hoffnung auf impfstoffe und
insofern stellt sich diese frage auch
sehr konkret dass wir nicht nur in
europa uns impfstoffe sichern so wie es
die europäische kommission tut sondern
dass dies auch insgesamt für die länder
der welt wichtig ist grundsätzlich haben
sich auch alle im g20 club dem
klimaschutz verpflichtet doch sobald es
konkret wird steht es weiterhin 19 zu 1
donald trump nutzt seine videobotschaft
um das pariser klima abkommen scharf zu
kritisieren
ein sehr unfaires abkommen für die usa
der pariser pakt wurde nicht entworfen
um das klima zu retten sondern um die
amerikanische wirtschaft zu erledigen
die usa hätten mehr für den klimaschutz
getan als alle anderen nationen so trank
ein teilnehmer hat auch noch mal die
gelegenheit genommen seine eigene
großartigkeit zu schildern
es klingt nicht so als ob europa trump
schwer vermissen werde der nächste
g20-gipfel findet im oktober in italien
statt dann mit dem neu gewählten us
präsidenten joe biden in guatemala haben
demonstrierende das parlament gestürmt
und in brand gesetzt sie protestierten
damit gegen den zuvor verabschiedeten
staatshaushalt mehrere menschen erlitten
rauchvergiftungen
zuvor waren hunderte vor dem kongress in
guatemala stadt gezogen
sie forderten den staatschef auf
zurückzutreten seine partei hat er den
milliardenhaushalt mitbeschlossen
inklusive neuer schulden und weniger
geld für bildung und soziales erfreulich
es kommt von den skispringern die wir
haben einen traumstart in die neue
saison absolut gleich zwei dsv-springer
auf dem podium heute nach platz zwei im
mannschaftswettbewerb gestern hat markus
eisenbichler heute den weltcup im
polnischen wisla gewonnen und zwar von
seinen teamkollegen karl geiger
naja ein bayerischer urschrei als erster
ausdruck der großen freude für markus
eisenbichler ist es der perfekte start
in
neue saison als drittletzter geht er im
finale in die spur
voller selbstvertrauen nach einer sehr
erfolgreichen sommervorbereitung nach
137 einhalb metern im ersten durchgang
reichen dann 134 zum sieg auch weil er
bei der landung hier den griff in den
schnee knapp vermeiden kann begeisterung
bei bundestrainer stefan horngacher denn
auch der beste deutsche des letzten
winters karl geiger ist schon in topform
er wird zweiter vor dem österreicher
daniel huber viel besser hätte die neue
saison für die deutschen skispringer
nicht anfangen können bobpilot francesco
friedrich ist auch zu beginn der neuen
saison in der erfolgsspur
in sigulda gewann er wie gestern den
wettbewerb im zweierbob jubel bei
bobpilot francesco friedrich über den 38
weltcupsieg seiner karriere gemeinsam
mit anschieber alexander schüler
dominiert der deutsche auch am zweiten
tag des weltcup auftakts im eiskanal von
sigulda bestzeit in beiden läufen und
wie schon gestern der sieg in lettland
bundestrainerin es kann erneut ein
bärenstarkes mannschaftsergebnis
bejubeln johannes lochner fährt
gemeinsam mit anschieber erich franke
mit zwei zehntelsekunden rückstand auf
platz zwei
als drittes deutsches duo landen
christoph hv und islam uhr auf rang vier
hinter dem stärksten schweizer bob
gelenkt von michael voigt und in der
fußball-bundesliga hat mainz mit 3 zu 1
in freiburg gewonnen und damit den
ersten saisonsieg gefeiert
das war es wettermäßig beginnt die neue
woche unterschiedlich im norden und am
alpenrand länger freundlich sonst
wechselnd oder stark bewölkt und etwas
regen an den küsten einzelne schauer
höchstwerte zwei bis elf grad
um viertel vor zehn begrüßt sich
christian sievers im heute-journal wir
danken für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen
noch einen unbeschwerten sonntag und
empfehlen jetzt controller banerjee und
berlin direkt